i i kind of want to bring it back to the
truckers because i i think we have to
examine what did these truckers do
[Music]
i can tell you i can tell you actually
we have this story from global news
canada
a few nights ago
we read the toronto sun that claimed the
truckers were far right racists you know
nazis who stole food from the homeless i
kid you not check this one out security
experts concerned about possible threat
financing tied to trucker convoy what
they say canadians ought to be worried
about whether crowdfunding websites
could be used to finance hate groups and
other extremist organizations financial
crime and security experts warn as the
so-called freedom convoy enters its
second week of protests in ottawa hard
questions are being asked about a
gofundme campaign set up by convoy
organizers and whether any of the 10
million dollars raised so far might have
come from malevolent sources keen on
wreaking havoc in canada security
experts also say they're worried about
the lack of transparency surrounding the
fundraiser and whether any of the
donations could end up in the hands of
hate groups or people who promote
hateful ideologies including people who
attended the protests carrying nazi
flags and the flags of known terrorist
groups oh heavens
well they're basically
well there's let me read this quote
the way that we're sort of talking about
this now this event is sort of like an
extremism event so i would argue that
this sort of a component of extremism
financing this is said jessica davis a
financial crimes expert and president of
insight insight threat intelligence yo
working class people standing up against
tyrannical government are being called
terrorists ian you were thinking about
911 jessica davis is like it's sort of
like a sort of a thing sort of
so no it's not you're saying actually
but but this is such slander such
vicious destruction of of the truth
there was like i think one or two guys
with some weird flags they got kicked
out of a rally when they were there by
the protesters these are blue-collar
individuals realizing that the entire
system collapses without their
participation and they're being vilified
they're getting attacked on on things
that they have never done and and
it's just mind-boggling to see this this
huge full frontal assault with
blue-collar people representing the will
of the people there's new poll numbers
coming out from canada specifically
highlighting how the majority of people
in canada want to get rid of all
restrictions so far as of today denmark
finland norway the czech republic the
united kingdom dropped all of their
coveted lockdowns and restrictions
canada wants to do the same things the
people there want that same thing the
truckers there are trying to push those
policies and the government instead of
hearing out the people meeting them
halfway seeing what they actually want
they're just calling them racists and
attacking them on things that have
absolutely no merit at all which is
disgusting
absolutely disgusting behavior that's
disturbing dude no marin in truth at all
i knew they could do this this this
weird slander thing but i didn't know i
didn't know when i was like 25 or 30 how
intense and relentless it could be and
how they just keep using the word
terrorist uh extremist what are these
other words they were using in the in
the reasons for canceling this stuff uh
they use these buzzwords
uh hate hates another one they use these
words hate groups hate so it's just pure
fascist manipulation it's they're losing
i know it's but it's what do they do
when they're losing it's they've got a
super saiyan yeah you got to watch out
that they don't say super saiyan yeah
watch out that these crazy militaries
don't go insane because they think
they're losing they are losing they are
losing the best strategic win
uh that's come from this trucker convoy
and it's not it's not really the protest
i think the strategic win for them is
how the government's reacting
to their protest
it's not what they're doing
because i mean i i'm a person that
believes that things got to get a lot
worse before they get better and there
hasn't been and again i haven't really
been keeping up with this i've heard
but
to date there hasn't been a clear
uh
a clear way where the government you
could see the government's overreach
than we're seeing with the canadian
trucker thing we've seen this here and
but when it comes to when it comes to
canada we're seeing like this
manipulation
of not only the media the government
that city council that says that they're
mercenaries that's where the real win is
it's the exposure that the canadian
government uh is is is getting from it
yeah i agree it's first time i've ever
seen the canadian government uh
completely oblivious and ignorant of its
populace that's usually government
always
from my perspective from the way i've
been seeing them uh but but you know
this is not a surprise here but but this
also speaks to the true power that these
truckers have and what kind of threat
they are to the establishment that
they're pulling out all these stops all
these incredible stealing people's money
to the like
so i was on reddit earlier i'm on reddit
all the time i'm just browsing through
it and it's it's a leftist propaganda
machine don't get me wrong and i saw
this image
this image this is from george
alexopolis we have several of we have a
bunch of his art up on the walls here in
the studio because he's incredible and
he has this really really great he's
been doing these satirical
cartoons mocking
the mainstream media
and this one shows
a trucker convoy but the trucks are
wearing clan hoods and and with tiki
torches or something
and there's a sign that says fakism like
fascism but it's spelled wrong
and then it says like oh 106
so he's clearly mocking how the media is
going after the truckers this was on
reddit on our slash picks
and i thought it was hilarious because
it was getting upvoted to the top of the
page like people were actually i think
it's because they use bots to upvote
leftist propaganda but whoever put it in
didn't realize he was making fun of them
and all the comments were like this is
the stupidest thing i've ever seen i
don't understand they spelled fascism
wrong the truckers aren't fascists all
of the comments were like this is a
workers uprising these are regular
people and i was like whoa
dude why why are the commenters
like
not part of the propaganda machine like
they're they they realized what was
going on in the lies i guess they
removed the post maybe once they
realized it was making fun of the
mainstream media but to see the comments
on reddit
understand this is this is a bunk idea
and the truckers are good and they're
hard-working people standing up for
their rights that was kind of surprising
absolutely and when you see
the larger kind of implications here
there's no demands by the truckers that
have anything to do with any kind of
larger political ideology instead it's
it's all about getting rid of the
restrictions the lockdowns the vax
mandates and specifically the border
restrictions which would hinder and
disrupt the global supply chain why is
canada implementing a vax passport
system on the border disrupting the
global supply chain more than it already
is disrupted it's a it's a situation
that has absolutely no merit no science
behind it no data people realize it's
bunk it's idiotic the uk government and
many other governments are not following
any of this bull crap anymore and the
people are there are saying we're just
sick of it we're done with it we want
our lives to return to normal that's
what they're asking for they're not left
they're not right i haven't seen any
major kind of larger political
ideologies other than stop with this
nonsense stop trying to control our
lives that's all i've seen yeah i saw
one report the truckers are saying
they'll stay until may yeah they'll just
they'll just hang out and
and these people that are claiming
they're like keeping up at night
apparently that's not true i was
listening to viva fry's live stream
and he went around talking to people and
they said they stopped blowing their
horns around 10 p.m
because the truckers realize they're not
protesting people and so he basically
just said that they're just they stopped
around 10 and then the the assumption is
yeah the truckers don't want to piss off
regular people but they're putting out
these lies to the best of their
abilities and then you look at these
social media platforms and they're
actually arguing that working class
people rising up against the machine are
the fascists
dude it's not working anymore cnn the
implosion the narrative the lies it's
kind of crazy because this is an
election year
last year was kind of chill because it
really wasn't there some elections and
now
in the first in the first month we get
swatted twice right we're getting we're
getting cyber attacks and now you've got
the popu this this populist uprising and
the establishment just goes nuclear and
destroys instantly all their credibility
like their credibility evaporated so
quickly among regular people i was
surprised to see it so you're big on
having law enforcement in studio huh
what do you mean
with getting swatted well they we they
came in the first now bringing me on
what was that and now bringing me on
well
you know that i think they swatted us
because of marjory taylor green but i'm
like i don't care like we're gonna have
her back she came on the show yeah and
we're gonna have a round of applause
it's insightful yeah i missed her to
listen to the house
that's what they're mad about that's
what they're mad about because she
explains how these people in congress
don't actually do their jobs they just
leave and like they don't know but no
one even votes they do like just they uh
they say yay or nay and they sound so
similar the words yay and they sound so
similar so it's like i can't wait to do
this joke i'm gonna do it it's gonna be
so good okay everyone in favor yeah
everyone against
they vote with their voice dude in
congress maybe you already know that no
no no but it's not just that it's like
there's only 10 people
she's like there's only 10 people
sitting there going like
okay next
next and they're just approving and
sliding things through that they never
even read yup and they're making things
into law affecting people's lives
destroying their livelihoods destroying
their existence giving us more
bureaucracy with something that they
don't even understand that special
interests literally write up for them
give it to them and they just pass it on
through and make it law that's how a law
is made special interests literally just
create their own rules that's the laws
we're living under especially with what
gofundme just did right now i think
there's also a reason that they did this
on a friday evening
because obviously people are tuned out
people aren't paying attention people
are out trying to go out and have a
drink and party and relax and forget
about the work week and i think they're
trying to you know make sure that this
doesn't get a lot of attention but
freaking yo i just i just want to just
to say this
if you're not following george
alexapolis on instagram you need to
follow g prime85 on instagram
cause he gets his he gets his art pulled
off of instagram every so often and his
jokes are just 10 out of 10 and i can't
even i can't even show you some of them
because they're they're they're edgy
they're really funny it's really really
great so g prime 85 g prime 85 we
actually have his art with like joe
biden using the force lightning and
vaporizing a crowd of people
it's just really really i saw that
picture of the trucker convoy that with
the kkk helmet on or whatever and i was
like oh what is this trash propaganda
and then i looked down and i saw g prime
i was like yeah that's what i thought it
was when you guys pulled it up he's got
he's got he's got another one i i don't
think i can yeah i was thinking about
showing it i can't that one's spicy
but i gotta say his latest drawing i
think maybe his greatest work yet yes
and it's about the truckers and i saw
people tweeting it not realizing he was
making fun of the media
and i was laughing for like 20 minutes
straight that's how good it is and it's
so offensive that youtube probably won't
allow us to show it
so i don't you follow g prime85
seriously it's it's that good thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you